the hunt
you know the drill
predator gets hungry
predator hunts prey
predator kills
right
[Music]
wrong
sometimes the prey fights back
team members get confused
major screw-ups abound
but the hunter who pays attention to all
the disasters
survives
six predators with amazing weapons
show us what it really takes
to make the ultimate kill
a prehistoric monster waits for the
morning sun
on this indonesian island he rules
supreme
this 300-pound komodo dragon is the
heaviest lizard on earth
he's a 10-footer
equipped with three-inch claws
and a phenomenal sense of smell
as the temperature approaches a hundred
degrees fahrenheit the dragon heads for
a water hole
this is where russo deer quenched their
thirst
the deer notice him
watching them
they're not giving up their drink for
such a slow predator
the dragon casually ambles closer
he waits
and then
just when they're lulled into a sense of
security he makes his move
it's a fail
deer are fast
they're gone
what went wrong
the dragon played the part of innocent
bystander and worked himself closer his
top speed is 12 miles per hour
much slower than a deal
[Music]
normally he'd ambush his prey from a
yard away
[Music]
they saw him
triggering the deer's flight response
more importantly
he couldn't deploy his secret weapon
changes up his strategy
growing up here it's a dragon eat dragon
world
komodos
are cannibals
[Music]
especially of the young and innocent
it's also young and agile
out of reach the adult waits patiently
young dragons make up a tenth of an
adult dragon's diet
the youngster senses that this is his
only safe spot
he's right
adult komodos are clumsy climbers
and the light tree branches might break
under his 300 pound weight
in this round youth trumps aid
another fail
the hungry stomach of the komodo
grumbles for a new strategy
if you can't kill your own
then go for leftovers
the beach is a big plate of discarded
food
his flickering tongue pinpoints nearby
carcasses
he essentially tastes the air by picking
up molecules and delivering them to the
jacobson's organ kind of super nose
inside his mouth
something smells good
to him
[Music]
several movable jaw joints let him
expand his mouth wide enough to vacuum
the fish down whole
bones and all
good thing
he hasn't eaten in days
he could gorge almost 80 percent of his
body weight the equivalent of 1200
hamburgers
in one sitting
but this meal is just scraps
yet every little scrap counts
[Music]
perfect
but another dragon is already dining on
the prize
now to steal what little is left
a little intimidation and our
opportunist
dives in head
first the smaller dragon stands by
and watches the curious show
[Music]
today
he's a jack of all trades
and master of none
by afternoon the dragon is ravenous and
is bent on making a kill
a water buffalo retreats to a cooling
mud bath
and the dragon dreams of slaying
the prey outweighs the hunter by over
1500 pounds
has hunger clouded his judgment
buffalo aren't indigenous to the islands
and are far larger than deer the
dragon's natural prey
even a tiger
would think twice about taking one down
buffalo horns are five feet long
and buffalo weigh nearly 2 600 pounds
this hunk of muscle could inflict
serious damage
yet it could feed the dragon for a whole
month
as with the deer the buffalo doesn't
perceive the slow-moving dragon as a
threat
she can run at 30 miles an hour twice as
fast as the komodo
and yet the dragon thinks he's got a
chance
it's a poor grip
and the buffalo shakes free
he won't quit
and the water buffalo is getting vaguely
annoyed
the dragon watches as his prey slowly
escapes
but in his mind it's game on
now the clock is ticking a predator
smackdown is about to happen
[Music]
our komodo dragon is facing off with a
buffalo
almost nine times his weight
it's playing out as the dragon
anticipated
even though he's nowhere near the
buffalo
he has an invisible weapon
venom
his bites released a unique lizard venom
into the buffalo's bloodstream the
venom's compounds are as potent as those
of the world's deadliest snake and will
soon send the buffalo into shock
with a bite force of almost 60 pounds
per square inch
the dragon's 60 serrated teeth
inflict the gaping wound
and with the thrust of his muscular neck
deliver the toxic cocktail one inch deep
into the buffalo's flesh
[Music]
now he follows
and waits
with favorable winds he can pinpoint his
prey's exact location over six miles
away
as the venom courses through the
buffalo's body it stops the buffalo's
deep wound from healing
its blood pressure drops
and it weakens
the buffalo's waterhole adds a second
invisible force
bacteria from the feces-filled water
which enter the wound and all but
guarantee a noxious infection
the buffalo takes one last stand against
the dragon
shock sets in
and its body begins shutting down
it's dinner time
whether the dragon likes it or not the
big buffalo will be eaten family style
it's been a long drawn-out hunt but his
venom weapon worked perfectly
it was deployed with just one bite
so he avoided injury
imagine a predator so strong it could
outbite a lion a tiger and a bear
this beauty scours the african plains
for her next meal
hyenas are efficient scavengers but can
hunt if needed lately she's had some bad
luck
her cubs need her protein-rich milk
and she can't produce it if she doesn't
eat
she needs food
and she needs it now
she detects a faint whiff of carrion and
heads in that direction
she can smell meat from over a mile away
across the plains lions have killed
they're feasting on a wildebeest and
she'd love a part of it
other hyenas have the same idea
but there's no hospitality
[Music]
lions kill heights regularly
just last month her mother tried to
steal a meal from two lions
[Music]
it was a gruesome loss
she knows the risks but hunger trumps
caution
[Music]
these lions will defend their kill at
all costs
but she still goes for it
a ravenous hyena leads a face-off with
lions
she moves in
[Music]
and just manages to escape
what went wrong
she joined forces with two fellow hyenas
to muscle in on the lion's kill
to get it right the clan needed four
hyenas to every lion
but without reinforcements
the three lions were just too strong and
the plan backfired
there's no point wasting any more energy
here
when the stealing gets tough
the tough go hunting especially when all
over the plains
deliciousness abounds
the male toki are engaged in their
once-a-year sparring competitions
to secure a mainstream
and some
are just plain exhausted
she watches them closely
her strategy
hit them when they're down
she sneaks up close
hoping to go unnoticed
it's a miserable attempt
[Music]
she had no plan at all
and just tried to creep in and secure a
hold on the toby as it lay dozing
her approach gave her away
the big antelope was just too strong and
quick
topi are one of the fastest mammals on
earth and can run at 50 miles an hour
that's 10 miles an hour faster than
height
back to the drawing board
the topi need to settle before they can
try again
she heads further across the plain where
her intent is not yet suspect
her plan is to get a grip with her jaws
hyenas have the strongest bite in the
mammal kingdom and exert up to a
thousand pounds of pressure
if she can get a hold of any part of the
toe
her huge jaw and powerful neck muscles
normally designed to lift heavy prey
will enable her to hang on
bingo
another target
she stalks in closer
[Music]
she loses her prey
but that's not all
this toby fights back
double fail
what went wrong
the topi started running before she
could bite down
still she got a grip
but he just steamrolled it
toby weighed 300 pounds and they're tall
she weighs 150 pounds her only real
weapon is her strong mouth the force of
the prey's weight outperformed the force
of the predator's jaw then the hunted
turned the tables on the hunter and
attacked
the toby's 15-inch horns could have
caused serious
damage
if she'd been hurt
her hunting would be over
to bring down one of these toby she's
going to need support
there's no shortage of help in a hyena
clan
it's run by the dominant females and is
like an all-girl gang
males are smaller and the females
control access to food
mating and the pecking order
she gathers a hunting party and heads
back
now she has some firepower
even grandma is in the mix
the topis spot the group immediately
a hunting party is much more obvious
than a sneaky single
soon enough
they go back to grazing
and dozing
[Music]
[Applause]
the two lead hyenas approach cautiously
quietly the sleepy toby
is oblivious
this hyena and her clan are hunting a
token
the front teeth interlock allowing the
hyena to hold the struggling buck very
efficiently
this topi has two bear traps attached
it's a victory
each hyena can eat 40 pounds of meat
bone and horn in one sitting
soft belly
300 pounds of hungry hyena weight tired
the toby out quickly
[Music]
hunting is way more expensive scavenging
but this time they got a high return on
their investment
more often than not they just steal from
other successful killers
even if that hunter is an infamous 60
pound dog
african wild dogs are just that
true dogs while hyenas are actually more
closely related to cats
[Music]
when the two cross paths
they fight like cats
and dogs
hyenas are three times a dog's weight
but the dogs are faster
the smaller dogs band together to target
the hyena's soft hindi
and use their numbers against her
her only defense is to hole up
they must beware
of
the hyena stays put
until the dogs lose interest
the dog pack is run by the alpha male
and female
their pups are just six weeks old
the pack must hunt daily if they're to
feed this high-energy brood
mom and dad rally the troops
the alpha male relies on his sharp
hearing to locate prey
today
he hears impala
some stuck in
others fan out to attack the herd from
all angles
[Music]
the dog's strategy is to work together
as beaters to flush the prey out into
the open where the other pack members
can attack
[Music]
the impala scout
their tactic is to zigzag their way
through the bush
but the dog pack can circle the hurt
as the impala cut across the curve the
dogs narrow the gap
wild dogs have the stamina to maintain a
speed of 35 miles per hour for three
miles
so it's a long chase
finally they have their target
as they close in
the terrain suddenly changes
the plan
goes dead in the water
the dogs are scared of crocodiles
so the deep river stops them short
it's a fail
their plan
seemed solid
they split up isolated one impala from
the first
[Music]
the prey had its own strategy
it deliberately ran into the water
this was a smart counter
with only a 33 chance of being taken by
a crocodile versus over 80 percent
chance of being caught by the dogs he
chose right
the pack regroups and heads back to the
den during the heat of the day
they'll wait until dusk before hunting
again
wild dogs expend loads of energy on a
single chase so this pack needs a payoff
soon
high-pitched twittering conveys their
excitement
it's time to hunt again
the alpha male takes the lead
impala again
the dogs split up to take their flanking
positions around the prey
as africa's marathon runners the dogs
are equipped with large hearts and lungs
to assist with speed and endurance
while their large ears act as heat
radiators to help keep them cool
the dogs hunt hunted relay taking turns
to run down the impala until it's
exhausted
but the impala makes for the same river
impala
know it
[Music]
this time
the dogs crossed downstream
[Music]
success
the impala was exhausted from the chase
and the swim used every bit of energy it
had left
the dogs got clever using a shallow
crossing in the river
dogs don't like water
unless there's meat within their grass
like the hyena they disembowel their
prey
but here there's no hierarchy
every dog has a spot at the table
they'll consume the impala in less than
10 minutes
but they aren't the most ruthless
predators out there
the bald eagle
symbolizes beauty
strength and independence and unlike the
dogs
hunts alone
[Music]
it's a hardcore hunter
to survive the bald eagle needs to eat a
full pound of fish daily
but today
this one decides to change the menu
a flock of coots
a coot weighs 1.7 pounds and this
opportunistic hunter will not pass up a
protein-rich meal
especially since the coot's calm nature
makes them an easy target
[Music]
they're essentially
sitting ducks
[Music]
the approaching eagle has the advantage
of 90 miles per hour
a perfect execution
or is it
[Music]
predators fill the sky
and he's under attack
they're here to steal not hunt
it's not easy to outfly a flock of
hungry birds with the extra weight to
carry around
he's intimidated
but its freedom is short-lived
the battle is not over
our proud hunter is determined to win it
back
and he does
for a quick second
now it's a battle in the sky for
possession of the prey
he snatches it back
what happens next is truly extraordinary
our hunter desperately clutches his prey
[Music]
[Applause]
the battle is over and his catch is gone
but
he doesn't lose his cool
he may not be an expert fighter
but he's a good hunter
[Music]
he catches another coupe by surprise
he dives too far down
his feathers are waterlogged
now
he could drown
all he has to do is let go of the coot
but he's not giving up
typically fish don't fly and birds don't
swim
but he'll have to break the rules
he tries out a kind of butterfly stroke
using his strong wings
but with every moment spent in the icy
waters he risks hypothermia
amazingly
he still rips the coot
he's exhausted
but alive
the injured coot has no hope of escaping
safely away from thieving eagles the
predator claims his hard-earned meaning
the eagle turned the failure of his
first hunt into opportunity
while the others were still fighting
over his prey he nailed another coot
it went downhill
the eagle weighs 14 pounds and a little
water along with a two-pound coupe meant
he had to get delayed quick
risk hypothermia and drowning
he innovated and started paddling
pray in tow
the talons possessed ten times the
grasping strength of the human hand
he turned three fails into immediate
success
a real triumph
the hunt
was a risk but it's nothing compared to
another eagle that goes for a bird twice
as large as the coot
[Music]
she finds it on east africa's vast soda
lakes
here flamingos gather in the thousands
to feed on the microscopic blue-green
algae and crustaceans found near the
water surface
their bills are like a filtered bathroom
sucking in the most nutritious food
like the bald eagle this african fish
eagle is going in for some bird on bird
action
the flamingo weighs nine pounds
that's two-thirds the eagle's own weight
and it's five inches taller than the
hunter
how to even begin
[Music]
first she must single one out
luckily her eyesight is one of the
sharpest in the animal kingdom
eyes on the sides of her face allow for
an extreme 340 degree field of view
nearly all the way around her head
while her visual accuracy comes from the
one million sensory cells in her eyes
that enable her to see five times
farther than humans and allow her to
locate her prey from over 650 feet away
she can see five basic colors
compared to our three
giving her a super ability to pick out
highly camouflaged prey
the birds on the outer edge
suspect a threat
[Music]
panic spreads quickly throughout the
tightening clock
the eagle scans for any sign of weakness
and identifies one flamingo isolated
from the rest
full-on attack isn't going to get her
anywhere with such large prey
her strategy
is to tire it out
her presence causes it to run along the
surface and flat frantic as he tries to
take off
[Music]
but every time the flamingo is thwarted
the flamingo is losing energy fast
now
the eagle gears up for her final mastery
move
the eagles hunt is going according to
plan
she's isolated the flamingo and is
wearing it down
now
to collect her award
but it's too heavy
if you can't go up
try going down
she pushes the flamingo underwater
hoping to subdue it
now to get it to shore
but suddenly she aborts the operation
it's a fail
what happened
flamingos spend 80 percent of the day
feeding to keep their energy levels up
the eagle's strategy was to isolate a
straggler
and tire it out with dive bombs until it
used up all its energy and was too weak
to escape
[Music]
but the nine pound flamingo weighed too
much for her to carry so she dunked it
and then tried to get it to shore
like the bald eagle did with the coop
but a minute into it she realized she
didn't have the strength
[Music]
sometimes you have to know when to quit
what's the point of calories gained from
this meal if it costs even more calories
to get it
hunting costs energy especially when
you're still learning how to do it right
this young leopard
searches for supper
he's been with his mother for nearly two
years but now he's on his own
at this point he'll eat anything even
porcupine
his prey doesn't need to run they have a
built-in fortress
but he's too inexperienced to know that
thirty thousand twelve inch quills stand
between him and a meal
he knows they're vulnerable from beneath
but he can't figure out how to get there
he has the right idea but his execution
is far from perfect
the quills can lead to septic wounds
that can be fatal
the lever tests the limits
unsure
a backward charge says back off
one zero to the port
this was a tough lesson
he knew what he had to do
flip one porcupine over to inflict a
lethal fight but he was just too
inexperienced in his attack
and the porcupine stuck together making
it harder for him
in the end
he was lucky to escape with a sore paw
he could have paid with a long and
painful death
unable to run with his hurt paw he tries
a completely different strategy
he can't sprint
but he can jump
the planes are full of impala
a leopard's coat is perfect for treetop
camouflage
he waits for the unsuspecting impala to
come within striking distance
his attack must be perfectly timed
[Applause]
he misses and gives chase
leopards can normally reach 35 miles an
hour
but he has a quill in his paw
double fail
this plan was solid a silent attack from
directly above
leopards are strong and agile enough to
pull this off
to break his 30-foot fall he spreads his
body to increase drag
while his muscular limbs act as shock
absorbers
his range finding was dead off
but there was one critical problem his
jump was just too high and while he was
in the air the impala had time to get
out of the way
his strategy has promised
so he tries to get it
he finds a lower tree
and stalks in unnoticed
the impala come to feed
the perfect spot for an ambush
[Music]
got it
unlike wild dogs and hyenas he kills by
strangulation
his secret to success was a lower jump
and he spread his body
to cover a larger area
a leopard uses all four sets of claws to
immobilize prey the impala wasn't going
anywhere
this success
was forged out of failure
like all predators who battle to survive
it's the ones that learn from their
mistakes
the triumph
[Music]
you